now I told you my boy whiskey Pete
Houston
I think Houston Pete sir if I [ __ ]
that up whiskey Pete gave me a World War
one whiskey come on what it was from
World War want yeah you tried selfie
picture it oh dude he brought in the
green room we got [ __ ] up and I had
that he brought Pappy Van Winkle how was
the World War one whiskey well excuse me
sir World War one was in what 1978 1980
is when it ended 1919 footage also is
from this from 1915 okay so we're
talking about a hundred and
three-year-old 104 year old bottle of
whiskey have you ever tried anything
that's a hundred years oh I'm not sir
I've not I've not so it tastes like out
of wine that was 52 years old that's it
because I was my blood from a vampire
this World War one whiskey tasted like a
world one whiskey not my my taste buds
they're not there yet they're not there
yet
no it tasted like someone pissed in my
mouth
yeah and I you know I don't want to
spend my boy whiskey Pete like a dragon
peed in your mouth cause it's got to be
very high proof outlaw whiskey it
amazing I was like a dragon come down my
throat
it was disgusting huh and I went that's
fun yeah I didn't know what I'll say I
went that's fun and then the one thing I
did because I remember you said this
when we're drinking wine I went pretty
earthy man pretty earthy yeah
which made no sense many timeout whiskey
and well it's kind of like a spicy
earthy Neos huh you tell he's being
polite dude how about I got my kid eight
he won't pipe down cuz he every morning
I worked out on my pal time bike and he
wants his own so he has like this Batman
bike but it's not a stationary bike so
he rides it in my driveway like in
circles like a crazy man
you just keep I put music on from just
rides it while I'm on my peloton so we
worked out every morning and so he keeps
harassing me to get a peloton I was like
I've been looking looking then finally I
found when I posted on my Instagram Jim
finally found one people keep asking me
who makes that I posted on my story
fisher-price makes a kid's stationary
bike so but it connects via bluetooth to
no it's not my storage and it's on my on
the wall kid riding a bike for god sakes
sorry so wants to meet you he wants you
could his hair so I'm right next to him
so he rides when I ride but you said so
it connects via bluetooth to I
that screen so it's like a peloton and
then the the thing is he's a little
character and they have trails and so
he's going and staying with the trails
while I'm going oh it's cool
ha that's so we were down there for two
hours working out really
oh he's aldis down for that it's all he
cares them my sons called the great
relaxer not this one man he's like
what's that you could go ahead and I'm
gonna put my hands behind my head and
you know relax and watch something uh
yeah I mean he's a smart kid
little Palatine oh he's not well I'll
walk in the house and he's ready oh yeah
I walk in the house he's like this
come on Papa I'm like dude that's so
give you those cute oh my god but it's
good because I'm working out two three
times a day
no because you only go on if I'm on so
they probably get on the bike pedaling
deal I for you worked out he's at go
poppin all right let's do I so you get
you get yourself peloton's at it or do
you do some weight lifting stuff I get
some ISA come on bro you see the [ __ ]
see some stuff that we set up
you got some fake grass down there to I
like that I like turf oh yeah you got
that in a garage yeah bro come on that's
what I'm gonna do the same [ __ ] thing
I had that too in my house I like it a
lot
what a little fake turf doing that oh
yeah oh [ __ ] you know because I was
gonna do poured cement but maybe I'll
lay some fake turf down it's way better
way better much better looks cool yeah
I'm all over open up the garage
oh that's the tunes but YouTube playing
the TV all over the dunes I'm so psyched
you just gave me a great idea
oh thanks bran Don what bran Don
oh all right man yeah but peloton should
make one for kids men like it more cuz
this one even you know he's paddling
he's going but it's he can't get into
yeah yeah kids are young he likes that
one guts your son's gonna be a beast
yeah is just old beast and he's got your
hair his little pants oh yes oh my god
but everyone keeps a sitz fisher-price a
half Amazon for God's sakes fake psychic
from Massachusetts was recently arrested
because she convinced one of her
customers that her ten-year-old daughter
was possessed by a demon and she ended
up racking up a bunch of like fake
charges saying I can get this demon out
of your child if you pay me for this
ceremony and this and that she ended up
getting 70 grand out of this woman right
up also also an episode of True Blood
this happened in True Blood but isn't
the woman who spent 70 grand liable yeah
I agree
incredible [ __ ] so you shot a Ponzi
scheme that's not you bro shouldn't you
be fine for being dummy [ __ ] should just
lose the money for being a [ __ ] yeah
you shouldn't have that money who God
how does she have 70 grand to give away
when you're when she's that dumped I
feel like people who go to psychics are
generally rich or like have some money
to go and also not sometimes also dumb I
know a few people were broken with when
I was a kid the psychic okay
go [ __ ] yourself about mark yesterday
goes uh I forget Oh cuz I came out what
is today Wednesday for you it is and
yesterday I was doing something for
below the belt on us is Monday I got it
done below the belt
and I walk out in there shooting you
know that their their new football show
called forth and forever
yeah with Mark Sanchez and Adam raid
that kind of get them ready [ __ ] okay
Adam [ __ ] destroyed is in Arizona B's
he's so funny
so there was [ __ ] we got mom before yeah
so they have a podcast together and I
get out I walk in there and Marcos Oh
how'd you show guy your good man is
bringing on UFC fights you know some guy
that's over he's got a bet we just got a
bet that's showing knowing everybody
asking about fights you you'd be the
worst man like all the time is if their
knowledge was fine but you know yeah I
try to stay away from it yes yeah and
then there's a beating us these Conor as
good as they fit that serious but he's
dead he we just had a long talk it was
his car as good as they say is I go you
serious he is no is he I go dude we just
talked about this goes no I'm honestly
interested on it all right what do you
got so
we talked about Connor and he goes dude
you know because you know my favorite
fight cuz he's on get up which is my
favorite sports show on ESPN with
greenberg and he goes dude yo who's my
favorite fighter that Russian he's just
such a beast we found him I get up i
watch you get up every way or and no
wait for it and I go Russian I get up I
know
Kabhi was it on get up and he's not
Russian Technic I'm thinking I'm like
rushing us give Russian dude he's like
he just used to fight with Kimbo in the
bet in the streets of Miami oh I stopped
on it not Maz I wear this why don't do
these this what this is just why don't
do this here's what his name's Jorge Maz
what I just that guy go
he thought he's Russian he's got it imma
leave now Jorge is why when poor dude
Russian Jorge Masvidal he goes he's not
rushing you
I mean I literally got my car and Marc
Marc says wait I got it just seems like
such a smart guy but he's the bet he
just doesn't they don't know it isn't a
fighter I know he got my cousin all
right Marc Rory mazels Russian dude Iraq
we got a roast and let's get him on the
podcast well you have him and Adam on
together going through a 20 year old
woman was on her way back from Australia
to Manchester and she was very drunk
when she got on this flight so much so
that she decided to continue the party
throughout the flight she continuously
got drunk and started talking to people
around her and asking guys like oh do
you want to join me in the bathroom in
join the mile-high gave her six months
for that I'm in because we gave her
eight inches give it up that wasn't you
can see me this saturday Wilbert boss
she's hot a smock dude she never smoked
that wasn't the problem though the
problem was that people around her asked
her to keep it down and then the flight
attendant said ma'am we can't serve you
any more alcohol she got really angry
and started to just lose her [ __ ] she
was biting people she was speaking and
tip took six people to finally I'm
really not a she's not a good drunk
she's scrappy not a good drunk she's a
little contrite there she's not in a
good mood
she's the POW DG a bad bad girl Shannon
girl mad daddy she's sorry great flier
miles
she needs somebody keep her on a
straight oh you need you need wings want
your little wings you want some nuts
with your wings you go by let me get my
let me get my wrist guard on my belt you
just reach 10,000 feet Wi-Fi in your
mouth Oh who's I telling you last night
there's like a group of like cholo
Mexicans hanging around the store and
they go hey homes are you not you know I
have my whole Mexican Betty goes are you
not Mexican
yo know your [ __ ] me man I know it's not
asleep back here God dude you look more
mixing this I'm like no I don't homeboys
they had the whole the thing tied the
family biggest fans are dudes like that
oh yeah the best they're always the best
fans actually those guys take it easy
they are they're always the most
enthusiastic okay if I'm at the football
games like just punch it it's like a
whole group might all [ __ ] look like
rough dude why would I give that to you
as it's a gift it's a gift